hi everyone and welcome to mi t--'s 2020
online commencement only when we are
aware that our time is nearing an end do
we actually make the most of the time
left and live in the moment so I urge
you all class of 2020 to live the rest
of your lives with the minds that you
likely had when you were told to be out
a week left in our college careers take
risks go all-in and shoot your shot find
the things that make you feel fulfilled
every day as you strive to hack the
world please try to heal the world too
please help us respond to this brutal
pandemic with wisdom foresight
compassion and science I want you to
promise me one thing
promise me that you will be the last
class the last class to miss a
commencement because of a pandemic the
last class to miss a commencement
because of war the last class to miss a
commencement because of climate change
unrest tyranny extremism active shooters
intolerance and apathy Batman and
Superman are not coming to save the
world it will be up to you but never
never in my life have I been so
confident that the fate of the world is
in good hands go forth and be the heroes
we need you to be so get some nice Cod
ribs and then get started
there is a lot of work in front of us
I asked you all now to raise your right
hand and turn your brass rap
[Music]
you